hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar
integration of three prime M RNA seek
and I clip to study the regulation of
alternative polyadenylation in Judea
leopards and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website the
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it brought to you by Lexington
Lexington is a transcriptomics and
next-generation sequencing company
focusing on the development of
technologies for complete transcriptome
sequencing its portfolio includes
innovative molecular biology tips
software and services for RNA seek to
learn more visit wlky.com let's get
started this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the CTE button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credit you can
post questions to the speakers during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click the green Q&A button to the lower
left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience technical problems seeing
or sharing the presentation just click
on the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
green to Linnae button at lower left I
now present today's speakers Gregor
wrote PhD and urinate Lulla PhD Gregor
wrote obtained his Master of Science in
computer science from the University of
Ljubljana in Slovenia and his PhD in
bioinformatics from the University of
Zurich in Switzerland Gregor is
collaborating with several research
groups performing data analysis and
developing express RNA org and
interactive research platforms for the
study of post-transcriptional
modifications
urinate Lulla changes PhD in molecular
neuroscience from the Rockefeller
University in New York and started his
research group at the MRC Laboratory of
Molecular Biology in Cambridge in 2013
he moves with his group to the institute
of neurology at University College
London and since 2016 the group is based
at the Francis Crick Institute the group
studies how protein RNA complexes
regulate gene expression this group
developed by Cliff a transcriptome wide
method that I get fights protein RNA and
RNA RNA interaction and living cells
with high resolution this method is
employed in combination with molecular
cell and computational biology study how
the structure and dynamics of protein
RNA complexes regulates neuronal
differentiation and functioning and how
their dysfunction contributes to
neurodegenerative diseases such as ALS
the group also studies the role of trans
poseable elements and non canonical
splicing events in the evolution of
alternative splicing doctor wrote will
now begin his presentation thank you for
the introduction and welcome to
everybody attending and in this webinar
we'll be talking about free payment
sequencing data to study alternative
poly relation and we will look on how to
integrate this data with I keep data so
Arnie protein binding data to better
understand the process of alternative
correlation and we will be doing this by
looking at a platform called Express RNA
that we developed to integrate all these
kinds of analysis together so but first
a little bit to zoom out on the topic of
pollination and cleavage and
polarization in general so if you look
at the line here in the middle of the
slides that represents the RNA you see
there are many protein complexes binding
on top of this around a political Asian
site so the point of cleavage cleavage
factor division poison relation
specificity factor and so on
so and you also see that there are
specific these elements on the RNA for
example the poly relation signal which
is the well-preserved
hexamer there is a you reach region and
there are you Jewish regions and other
elements and this whole clean jump
organisation free command processing
machinery is then also interacting with
other RNA binding proteins and we are
interested in what's more specific
protein we will be talking about our
specific protein tdp-43 which is
involved in neurodegenerative disease
and our studies interesting of how this
protein is disrupting poly relation so
preventing the three prime end
processing machinery of doing provision
poly generation and specific site and
switching this process to another site
mostly upstream of the gene so how to
study and how to develop software tool
to tackle this problem in a way so what
we did we developed a platform called
Express RNA and specific part of this
platform which is intended to study
gentle polarization is called Express
earn a dot Appa Appa stands for
alternative pollination and it handles
all the aspects of the analysis from
taking the raw sequence data to managing
containing the data using
state-of-the-art tools to map do it to
the reference genome then computing
differential modulation analysis and
either even going further and combining
this with alternative splicing and you
see later also with motive analysis so
express our RNA is feeling Tangut of the
post transcriptional analysis the
research tool so back to poison nation
alternative polyadenylation how to study
these processes so usually what you do
in this case the data is coming from
lexical controverse protocol you prime
with an oligo DT primer and by doing
this you can
only the end of the RNA molecule so the
molecule and the inter the resection
where the molecule is then put it in
elated and then we do high to put
sequencing and not to go into the Terran
you get millions of reads that are
containing the signal of where the RNA
was putting in elated and then you map
this reads back to the reference genome
and for example in this graphic I'm
showing you a distal site or a proximal
site and any good streets together and
here on the right to see you do a little
bit of clustering because cleavage in
coagulation is not a nucleotide exact
process so we have a 12 - 5 - 5
nucleotides in our case and after we
group these signals together you can
imagine that you have information
genome-wide manner of where pollination
is happening and not only where but also
the extent of the auto correlation in
the minute next question is if you have
your own data set you would like to
understand if the poly a site that you
are detecting are valid sites so if
other people already detected this poly
side that we are looking at and what we
do immediately here we compared our poly
relation database if you call it like
that or Atlas - to other studies by
dirty and Gruber and you see that the
coverage of the location of the poly a
sites is strikingly similar so there is
a little bit of change in a couple of
nucleotides because as I mentioned
before the cleavage is not a little
tight exact process so you have to
tolerate a little bit of change in this
way but then you do further analysis to
validate your poly a sites and here what
we do is we look at nucleotide
frequencies and on the left side you see
graphs from the from our data set that
we detected and that are also covered by
other data sets
you see the an a enrichment upstream of
the cleavage coagulation site which is
here in the center and you also see a
tee in Richmond downstream and this is
really a significant let's say pattern
of pollenization cleavage site that you
expect from your from your data set and
then you also look at our poly cited or
detected but not detected by other
studies you see a similar signature and
it's less pronounced but still this
gives you an idea that also the sides
that we detected in the third level are
also varied by generation sites and then
to further validate this we developed de
novo motif search algorithm and what you
would expect from these kind of searches
that also very well studied that the
poly relation signal is present 20
nucleotides upstream of the cleavage
site and it's very well-known also which
kind of signals the most frequent so
it's very well conserved hexamers AAT
AAA and variations on this theme and if
you look at all our detected polling
sites here in green you see the signal
is very strong and it's where it's
expected to be and you also if you look
now at the normal polling sites that we
detected without data set you also see
in this red dotted line that is pretty
strikingly overlapping and this is
another let's say this is evidence again
that the detected polling site pay sites
with our data sets with our data our
through polling sites next what we did
is we took our RNA seek data sets so
classic irony seek from access since
also our experiments were in Texas and
we were interested to see if we look at
the coverage of the RNA seek just
upstream of the detected polling sites
if the coverage is dropping and so here
on this
a graph upstream you see on the top you
see that in this green line there is a
drop in coverage just before you're
clearing site here and this is true for
the poly sides detected by our and other
studies and also for a little bit less
extent or two normal polling sites
between detect here in red and the
middle and the bottom heat maps they
show you the top coverage for jeans in
in terms of a single gene so each line
in the heat map is one gene and again if
you look at the RNA seek data you see a
drop in coverage if you look at lexicon
Quantic data you also see a striking
signal just before the polyadenylation
period site and this again shows you
that the data is valid so we went to a
lot of through a lot of work to really
validate the polling sites to show the
to working with really significant data
so if you imagine now where you know
where the polling sites are and so we're
polling elation is happening and you
also know the extent of it the immediate
question is how to detect genes which
are alternatively poly related so
whereas which occurs and regulation is
switched from a distant site to a
proximal site or vice versa and in the
beginning we had this simple approach
where we compared computed the percent
change and we looked at ratios between
the controls and the test so the
controls are wild-type cells in this
example and the tests are knockdown of
protein of interest and we classified
genes in three categories so genes where
the proximal site is upregulated in the
distal sized is down regulated genes
where we have observed no significant
change here in the middle and then also
genes where the proximal site is down
regulated and
distal site is upregulated talking in
terms of control versus test always and
we only look at to more significantly
changed for the insights per gene so we
decided to do this because if we look at
all the sides um it's very very becomes
very very complex and also in terms of
biology you always would expect to have
a very significant change a switch from
one side to one or two other side
maximum and how do we do it
currently with Express RNA so we use a
software called
Dex a quiz state of the art in terms of
looking at alternative splicing but
instead of providing counts for exomes
we provide counts for polling sites and
then this software tells us which
polling sites have significantly changed
and we select the two most significantly
change sides and we also require that
they change in the opposite direction
and by doing this we can really classify
each gene for which we detected at least
two so two or more poly donation sites
into one of these three categories that
I've been showing you in the previous
slide and we do it an additional
categorization so based on where the
selected proximal and distal sites are
in the gene we classified the genes
additionally into this same acts on
composite exon and skipped exon category
and for example the same action simply
means that the proximal distal sites are
in the same action it doesn't need to be
in the last x1 it can be in an actual in
between somewhere upstream and the
composite excellent skipped acts or
scenarios a little bit more complicated
so we also look at splice sites around
this site so this five prime splice site
and flips prime splice site because we
were also interested it will be later
evident in the so called RNA maps we
look at the beaming binding of a protein
to the RNA we also interested if
proteins
regulating oil inhalation and splicing
at the same time by binding around the
pollination site and also the 503 prime
splice sites and I would like now to
pass the presentation to your name okay
so I'll be happy to take over now so the
next question we wanted to understand is
whether the poly a sites that are
identified by Kwan cig are directly
regulated by specific RNA binding
proteins and really the goal of our lab
is not to identify poly a sites and
probably there are better methods and
Quantic to identify new pollinator sites
we are rather interested in
understanding which sites are regulated
and what proportion of those are
regulated by direct binding around the
poly a site which ones are regulated due
to the splicing changes as gregor has
just described and how this
combinatorics works when different
proteins assemble on the same RNA and
for this purpose we actually need to
integrate a variety of different
datasets so on one hand we in Gregor
described how this regulatory function
can be identified through the Quantic
which can be returned upon inhalation we
can also input into the pipeline that he
developed the Express RNA the
information about alternative actions
that can be identified through standard
RNA seek methods and then we want to
understand the different type of
interactive data that are enriched along
the sides so one method that we use in
the lab a lot is the I clip method and
on the other hand Gregor also works with
tools that can directly discover
regulatory motifs so now we have the
information about binding information
about regulation when we put them
together in different kinds of ways and
one way that we do this for just going
to
purposes is to draw this what we call an
RNA map where we are looking at the
positions were protein binds to either
enhance or repress the use of certain
poly I sides so as I described one
method we use is the eye clip this is a
biochemical method to define the size of
interactions between proteins and RNA
and one of the principal steps of the
methods is that you can cross link this
complexes in vivo so the interactions
are preserved and representing the in
vivo environment we fragment the RNA to
pretty short pieces and that ensures
that we will not get a lot of indirect
interactions we will mainly get contacts
of our protein directly to the RNA
rather than in purifying large complexes
of lots of interacting partners some
during our purification we locate an
adapter to the RNA and this adapter will
be complementary to the later primers
used for reverse transcription and in
order to be really stringent with our
methods we tend to visualize our
complexes on an SDS page gel so we can
first of all see that we are having only
the complex of interest present and that
the controls are clean and secondly it
allows further purification of the
complex and then we prepare the cDNA
library the central aspect of the I
click protocol is that it can actually
amplify the cDNA that translate at a
point of cross-linking it only allows
one adapter to be present on the RNA and
it can amplify this cDNA by introducing
the second adapter after the point of
reverse transcription and once you
sequence this data the analogies
actually relies on looking at the
nucleotide preceding the mapped reads so
the nucleotide on the genome that
receives the metric is where we expect
most crossing events will locate and so
that's the analogous
binding interactions through the
experiments and you can look here a
comparison of binding analogy that is
either based on the sequence so we
notice this protein that we study called
tdp-43
likes to bind ug rich sequences and in
this particular RNA you can see I just
put an arrow next to the site in the
intron where the protein has a strong
usually sequence and then another arrow
in the three prime UTR
and you can see the structure of the
gene here underneath so the the bigger
of locked regions are the exons and then
the arrows thinner line are the introns
and here we have an alternative exon
that is being regulated in red and
tdp-43 promotes inclusion of this action
and you can see that there are binding
events nearby the acne near the action
and that the regions of ugh sequence
tends to also overlap with regions of
strong cross-linking and generally we
see there is a close correlation between
the binding motifs of a protein and
cross-linking signature thing so next we
can understand how this correlation
between binding and function really
looks in a more systematic fashion
across the larger set of regulated exons
and this is where we come to this point
of looking at the data in the form of an
RNA map so in one hand I just noticed
noted before that there is a close
correlation between enrichment of
eugenic sequences and strong
cross-linking of the protein and on the
other hand we can see that the positions
were the protein cross-linked depends on
the function so here you can see a group
of RNAs which have strong cross-linking
of the protein just upstream of the axon
and exons and discuss all the repressed
exons
so that's what we see these blue dots
present action of the axon and similarly
we will have axons that will have
enrichment of a broad region downstream
of the action against those are
repressed axons
so whenever we make a blue line it means
that this is an x1 it will be skipped in
the presence of tdp-43
and then we see a large category of
axons which has binding just downstream
of the action and this action is tend to
be enhanced by did it before this tree
so very often you see that the same
protein can have dual functions it can
either enhance or repressed lighting and
here in this study we wanted to
understand is it possible that some
proteins will have even further
functions not only they can regulate
splicing they can also regulate triple
in processing and here is now the RNA
map of triggermen processing and it's a
little bit complex so I'll explain step
by step so first we can see it in the
same format as we did it for splicing
where we just plot every single RNA in
its own line and you can see generally
that binding of tdp-43 is quite enriched
just around the site of cleavage and
also close to the sides where the poly a
signal is located which indicates that
tdp-43 will tend to block this site and
hide them from recognition which is
completely some kind of consistent with
the fact that is repressing this site
and you can see the same type of a map
in a summarized format where we are now
not plotting every individual RNA but we
are summarizing data across all of the
regulating sites regulated sites and the
this map also involves some statistical
analysis so first of all I should be a
point your attention to this central
gray region in the middle of the map
which represents binding on RNA that are
not regulated which would be want to be
controlled we would consider control
RNAs so it's good to have some
information about how the protein
binding distributes in general around
poly a side and
that gives us then an idea whether the
regulated sides are any different from
any random sides and indeed they are
different so we see that when the
protein tends to repress to implement
processing you see these regions of blue
color so all the repressed sites are
plotted on the bottom underneath the
control side and these regions of field
blue region are regions of enrichment
with that we can be very confident about
because the blue line here the one that
I'm just going to plot an arrow to the
blue seam line is just the summarized
binding at all those RNAs but then you
have this gray region around them that
represents standard deviation of ten
60,000 bush shrub analysis of this
binding signal so it's telling you how
variability signal around and of
summarized binding so the fields blue
region is really taking into account the
variance of data as well as coverage so
the regions of field in Richmond is
really what we would consider
significant and reliable and you can see
that the regions of binding where the
protein tends to promote inclusion or
promotes recognition of processing tend
to be further away from the poly a site
and writer the poly a site the protein
will not bind when it's promoting a
recognition of the poly a side so that's
also regarded and reassuring that the
binding of the protein depends on its
function and you can see the same now in
this new slide where we just plot the
top-20 side which we have most binding
around repressed poly a site or enhance
poly a site miss addition zone of
exclusion for the enhanced site which
generally will not bind just next to
this cleavage event will bind further
away um so that's really what we are
interested in now our grouped
understanding positional patterns of
regulation and here you can see one
example gene you can
see how tdp-43 binds very strongly to
one specific region in the three prime
UTR
and this region is right next to the
proximal poly a side so the terminology
will use you directly one that creates a
short ERISA form is the proximal side in
the distal site rate belong to either
form and you can see the zoom in into
this proximal region and the poly a
signal of the proximal sequence is close
to where the tdp-43 cross-linking lives
and you can also see how the
cross-linking signal nicely overlaps
with the regions will receive usually
two sequences and the experiment we did
here was just to take this 3 prime UTR
sequence out of its context put it into
reporter assay and then measure the
ratio between proximal and distal
signals in the wild-type cells or knob
themselves and you can see that in the
knockdown cells we are now making more
of the proximal isoform normally TDP
binds there and repressors processing
but when you take it away we are making
more of the shorter lines of form and
when we mutate the tdp-43 binding then
the difference between vault up and
knock down is lost and actually already
in the control cells we will make more
of the proximal isoform because now we
are not inhibiting this site anymore and
finally we can actually see that this
function of tdp-43 can be replaced by
another protein so now we replace the
ugh sequences by you reach sequences
that tend to be bound by the Tia
proteins and indeed we now see that once
we do this replacement then the TF
knockdown
will lead to from would promote the
production of the proximal Iser form and
tdp-43 does not regulate the site
anymore and so it seems that this
regulation of poly a sites has similar
type of regulatory
positions regardless of which protein we
are looking at though this needs to be
explored more deeply now for larger
numbers of
now one way that we can also approach
this problem is not looking at a clip
data but directly looking at the
sequences of RNA and we've noticed that
a lot of RNA binding proteins tend to
recognize very short motifs on RNA
something they are made only of two or
three nucleotides and they can even be
degenerate sequences so it's quite
difficult to predict the binding sides
of any binding proteins but one way we
try to get around this problem of short
binding sites is that lots of RNA
binding proteins have multiple domains
often they also interact with each other
and assemble in larger kind of complex
in this multivalent type of recognition
and one way that one can try to discover
this sides then is to start by looking
at short sequences so we can start by
looking at rhymer stature momentum is
relatively short motives find the first
party that is enriched and then look is
there any further motif that is also
additionally reached when the first
multivision reached so we're now looking
at coupled enrichment of multiple motifs
and Gregor can explain more later on if
you're interested about how specifically
this statistical analysis works but just
to give you how this works in case of
them poly a sites regulated by tdp-43
if we look at the poly a site that our
proximal we see that when the sides are
repressed then the motif that is mostly
enriched in this first region upstream
of the poly a signal is the GU gene
motif and actually the same also happens
at the position that overlaps with the
poly a signal and the cleavage side and
interestingly when we plot this motif
around the two types of sites and
reached on our hand we see that the
region downstream of the cleavage site
will have enrichment and the enhanced
sign so again consistent with what we've
seen with the I clip data but the
advantage of this motif analysis that
sometimes it can also uncover other
types of motive that actually you would
not expect to be enriched they are not
known to bind to the p43 they enriched
in this
case downstream of the depressed site
that indicates maybe other proteins
binding in those regions and somehow
this proteins might be interacting with
tdp-43 or competing and kind of opens up
new opportunities for setting up new
hypotheses and again in this downstream
region the software also detected
enhancement of this ug rich motive so
basically this position dependent search
for cluster motifs is quite efficient in
uncovering regulatory motifs and it also
shows that the distal site can also be
directly regulated so for example it can
discover the ug rich motif also around
the distal site showing that for example
TD pathology can repress the use of
distal site if advanced nearby on this
side so it really shows how there's a
lot of different ways of tdp-43 can
regulate the comment processing and so
just to summarize this diversity of
regulation here actually was just
showing your data for the tendon sites
with Lego described earlier the tandem
sites of the ones that are present in
the same last axon we have lots of cases
of repression by binding just next of
the cleavage site enhancement very
buying further away we see that you can
also directly regulate distal sides and
what I haven't shown you is that we also
see a regulation of other types of poly
a size 4 numbers here the skipped events
so the ones where you have actually a
splice site in between and you have your
own different types of exons we again
see this for example enrichment close
the proximal side that are being
repressed
so just to wrap up I pass it back to
Gregor Thank You Renee so just a final
flight in terms of availability of
software in terms of analysis so express
our innate online web application when
for now you can explore the results the
tour
well here and it's composed of three
different Python modules so this upper
module which taking care of the free
primary sequencing data and the
processing and in this module integrates
several external state-of-the-art tools
for mapping to the reference genome
doing various analysis and so on so we
really took different software and try
and combine it together in a way to
serve our purpose our research goal the
RNA motives - is completely independent
Python module which is used to the
motive analysis that your name was
talking about in the previous slides
which you can download the new scooty
independently between the great editing
Express RNA and PI Bo it's a small tool
set of genome annotation tools so - it
facilitates the download of genome
annotation for example from ensembl and
if you have a genomic position and you
would like to know which genes annotated
- or if it intergenic so you can do
things like that with by Bo and I would
like to describe a little bit of video
that we would play for the end which I
cannot comment life but this video will
just show you how to use Express or na
online and how to explore it you will
see there is a Help section where we
describe the basic concepts and I think
in the NT resources here RNA pac-man
game which is still in development but I
think I'll be a lot of fun so we like to
ask now the moderators to play the video
keys
so we come to the last slide I would
like to thank Tamar shrew the University
of Ljubljana and mark and Christian from
the University of Zurich for all the
help with bioethics then inna
who is now politic in Heidelberg for
doing the experimental work for the data
that we were falling and Misha who is
finishing a PhD in Munich also for all
the help and ideas and Jen who is now
working for a start-up in Paris and she
did a lot of work in developing free
payment sequencing protocols and in a
Mira and Jen were all part of your nails
lab here in the picture and almost like
to thank you nee who was really
instrumental in designing the
experiments for guiding and also a lot
of ideas and help with bioinformatics
and motive analysis and I think we can
now move on with the question and
answers hey Rosie
ask your Gregor great thank you both dr.
Ruth exhauster grulla for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how is the NIT question
simply type them into the Q&A box down
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window dr. Ruth and dr. Luo will answer
as many questions as time permits and
first question is for you dr. look how
long is your usual poly a signal and is
it over three consecutive days or more
so it's a hexa nucleotide the most
common signal is a a UAA so you can see
in one of the slides we showed the I
think 12 most common hexa nucleotides
definitely a UAA is the most common one
is may be present at about 40 to 50
percent of the sides
I believe Gregor can correct me but this
is a well studied element that
has been characterized a lot by other
studies already so we just use it as a
quality control and it binds to the cpsf
component of the processing machinery
okay here is our next question also for
dr. Willa you showed slides by ron adele
2017 with that picture published alright
okay just a moment so that was slide 7
if I understand right I think you
probably are referring wrote that doll
maybe that was a misspelling in wrong at
all
and I'm pretty sure that it was
published what we have shown I believe
has been all published come so it may be
in the supplementary material of our
paper I'm pretty certain if I'm looking
at the right slide okay here's our next
question
um person says hi thanks for the
presentation and questions how much is
minimum coverage sequencing for upper
discovery so um the coverage is
difficult to estimate if you have around
a couple of million reads in an
experiment you can already start to draw
some conclusions from the full
experiment because especially it's
interesting because since you don't
sequence the entire transcript on but
you are targeting the end of the
molecules there are molecules
you need a lower coverage I would say
the next question is can I use Express
RNA for non-model organisms with genomes
not well annotated so thank you for the
question yes it's possible so Express
RNA will search in a modular way that
you can add external genomes for example
it's quite easy to add genomes that are
for example present in examples of any
genome that is available there
you can add to express our name in the
next one is for dr. rogue having to deal
with internal climbing events in the
mRNAs retrying and sequencing approach
and you have filtering approaches in
express RNA so yes we are aware that
internal priming is a big problem in the
field and what we do is we do two things
so first we look at the genomic sequence
surrounding the particular Asian cuit
sites and we filter out with certain
thresholds of a Richmond and the next
thing we do use a classification
software called poly AR and this
software classifies again it looks at
the sequence and it was trained on set
of sequences of poly sites and then the
software is able to classify a specific
poly a site into a strong weak or site
without a coordination signal and for a
very strict filtering we only look at
very on your strong side so we really
for some analysis wanted to avoid to
look at possible internal priming
artifacts Inc which is or could be the
most proper model species to analyze
motif complexity involved in a poly a
regulation yeast perhaps and who that
you never choose to answer that maybe I
can help here a little bit Janna here
and I would say in yeast generally
supply certain poly a sites are much
better defined so the canonical motifs
tend to be stronger and there are less
regulatory motifs involved so as we go
higher in Commandos the regulation
becomes more complex so I do think that
in order to model the regulatory motifs
you need to use the same species that
you will then use to discover the
motives so but I think also it's good to
have independent data to build a model
so I think the leap data and the fact
that we all kinds of keep data becoming
available publicly will be quite useful
because they get direct information of
the protein actually binding and once we
have enough proteins we can start
building kind of combinatoric models and
then that helps to go back to sequence
analysis you just want to be would be
for doctor wrote does express RNA
analyze both quad speaks forward and
reverse data yeah so we designed we
crafted the research platform such a way
that you can take divided different
kinds of reprimand sequencing data
depending on the protocol and it's a
quite easy just a switch actually to say
which type of data it is you know way
because there are small differences in
terms of where do you group the reads
after their next to the reference genome
either by v prime or free prime or if
you have to reverse the strand and other
specific technicalities like this so
yeah it can handle both types of data
and also not only consi but also other
types of data how do you define the PA
cleavage site for mRNA
so thank you inside to define this by
looking at the the data and then we look
at specific six elements surrounding it
and then we construct the coordination
database which contains all the cleavage
sites between the tected in the date I
guess I should add to that Gregor in
this case when we use Quantic data we
define a cleavage site based on the
Quantic data so in depends what is
forward or reverse gate so in case of
the reverse gate is actually the first
nuclear that you get when you start
sequencing that will be the position of
the cleavage sign in case of the forward
Kidd the algorithm that Gregor uses
relies on the reads that go into the
poly a tail the proportion of those
which tends to be quite high so you have
to trim those reads and after the
trimming the last nucleotide of that
read will be the cleavage side and it's
a composite analogous once you get
enough reads that you can be confident
and they survive the filtering then you
can assign that as a cleavage side did I
describe that correct
Gregor yeah it's it's correct okay okay
doctor wrote the necklace for you
waiting to pre-process my data before
using Express RNA so the data itself
doesn't need any pre-processing like and
I was describing depending on the data
we do trimming and other processing of
the really raw reads so the input that
you need for express RNA or fast queue
files for example with millions of
sequences okay next one is also for you
how do I analyze my quantity data the
Express RNA so for now the online
application doesn't allow users to
upload their own data for example to be
analyzed on our servers but that's in
Jan let's say so the way to go would be
to download the Python packages so opera
especially and set it up on your server
or your desktop computer since it's not
so CPU demanding
and then annotate your data and do then
is it there are some dependencies that
you would need to install like if you
want to use a specific aligner for them
to star or bowtie you would need to
install it separately and tell upper
where it is located but these are them
technicalities dr. Rudnick phone three
UK anyone Express RNA on our server or
exactly this is also connected to the
previous question and yes you download
the Python software you set it up and
then you can run it on them on a server
or on your desktop computer okay and yes
one is for you - how can I use Express
RNA to identify no chief enriched around
a predefined list of alternative exons
or poly a sites hmm so in this case if
you have list of excellence or polling
sites that you would like to search for
enriched motives I would suggest to
download the irony motives to package
which is also a Python software and then
you can look how to provide this list
into the software and just run the
analysis on your computer and it doesn't
need to be integrated with express or
innate motive analysis software is
completely independent we just
integrated it with the online web
applications it is very convenient to
run the analysis on the data I would
like to once again in Tata wrote
industrial ruler for their presentations
do you have any final comments for us
today doctor wrote yeah thank you for
for the opportunity and I'm very happy
to present our work and doctor little
would you like to share some thoughts
okay real close I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers by email we'd
also like to thank our sponsor Lexington
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CTE button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December 28th
2017 lab routes will alert you via email
and it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye